Today we continue our discussion of
when contracts are unenforceable because
they violate public policy.
We will look at it in 1987 Wisconsin
case called watt versus Watt,
where the court considered whether an
unmarried couples cohabitation agreement
is enforceable in what the watt,
the plaintiffs.
Sue Ann lived for 12 years
with defendant James.
The couple held themselves out to the
public as husband and wife and had two
children together but never actually
married. When the couple split up,
plaintiff sued under several theories
for a share of their property,
including the theory that she and the
defendant had a contract to equally share
all of the property accumulated
during their relationship.
The trial court dismissed the complaint
and the instant court reversed and
remanded.
The central issue is a contract
between the parties to share property
accumulated during their relationship
void as against public policy.
The Supreme Court of Wisconsin held that
enforcing such a contract would not be
void as against public policy.
The court began by observing
that non-marital cohabitation
does not render every
agreement between the
co-habiting parties illegal,
but the court also acknowledged that
a contract will not be enforced.
If it violates public policy.
Thus the defendant argued among other
things that the party's relationship was
immoral and illegal and
that any recognition of a
contract between the parties
or plaintiff's claim for a share of
the property accumulated during the
cohabitation contravenes public policy
contracts quote for which the soul
couldn't consideration is sexual
relations unquote are unenforceable,
but according to the court,
a bargain between two people is not
illegal merely because there is an illicit
relationship between the two.
So long as the bargain is independent
of the illicit relationship and the
illicit relationship does not
constitute any part of the concern.
Consideration bargained for and
is not a condition of the bargain.
Further,
the court recognized that a refusal to
enforce a contract between the parties
because their relationship
involved immoral or illegal
sexual activity would be
inequitable and arbitrary in that it
would leave one party no less guilty than
the other with a greater
share of accumulated wealth
merely because he or she
held it prior to trial.
Hence,
the court concluded that the plaintiff
pleaded sufficient facts necessary to
state a claim even though the
parties being in Pari delicto.
With regard to an uh,
tempted bribe was sufficient to make a
court refused to give any order of relief
in sign are in the sign.
Our case in Perry here,
the parties being in Perry delicto with
regard to illicit sexual relationship
was not at least by 1987 sufficient to
categorically keep a court from giving
relief. So what are the elements
of an unjust enrichment claim?
The plaintiff also asserted
an unjust enrichment claim.
We talked about unjust enrichment in an
earlier module when we looked at a case
called daily versus West.
What are the elements of an
unjust enrichment claim? Well,
in Bailey v West,
we saw that three conditions must be
satisfied for unjust enrichment. One,
there must be a benefit conferred upon
the defendant to the defendant must
appreciate the benefit.
And three,
it would be an equitable for the defendant
to retain the benefit without making
a payment to the plaintiff.
The court in watts versus watts considered
those same three conditions and held
that unmarried cohabitants may raise
claims based upon unjust enrichment
following the termination of their
relationship where one of the parties
attempts to retain an unreasonable amount
of the property acquired through the
efforts of both.
In other words,
even if the plaintiffs contract
claim failed on remand,
if she was able to satisfy the
elements of unjust enrichment,
she could still win the case.
Section one 78 subparagraph one of the
restatement of contracts provides that
quote,
a promise or other term of an agreement
is unenforceable on grounds of public
policy.
If legislation provides that it is
unenforceable or the interest in its
enforcement is clearly outweighed in
the circumstances by a public policy
against the enforcement of such
terms. Thus, if a constitution,
statute,
administrative regulation or local
ordinance preempts the enforceability
question by clear language,
the court's job is to implement
that legislative decision,
but if there's no clear
legislative mandate,
the promise or term is unenforceable.
If the interest in its enforcement is
clearly outweighed in the circumstances by
a public policy against the
enforcement of such terms.
This mirror is the approach the
court followed in watts versus watts.
The court first considered whether the
Wisconsin Family Code restricted the
court's resolution of property disputes
between cohabiting couples and it found
that it did not.
The court then enunciated a balancing
standard when it said quote a declaration
that the contract is against public policy
should be made to only after careful
balancing in the light of
all the circumstances of
the interest in enforcing a
particular promise
against the policy against
in its opinion,
the Wisconsin court is highly critical
of the Illinois Supreme Court's 1979
opinion and Hewitt versus Hewitt.
There the court held that quote allowing
such a contract claim would weaken the
sanctity of marriage unquote and violate
the policy of the Illinois Marriage and
Dissolution Act.
The court also emphasized legal
process stating that there are quote,
major public policy questions involved
in determining whether under what
circumstances and to what extent it's
desirable to cord some type of legal
status to claims arising from
cohabitation relationships.
The plaintiff argued that because of
changing social norms and attitude,
the court should abandon the traditional
rule that cohabitation agreements are
illegal,
but the Hewitt court responded,
quote the question whether change is
needed in the law governing the rights of
parties in this delicate area of marriage.
Like relationships involves evaluations
of sociological data and alternatives.
We believe best suited to the superior
investigative and fact finding facilities
of the legislative branch unquote.
In other words,
the court was reluctant to change the
law because of alleged changes in social
attitudes.
The court felt that legislators are
better position to verify broad social
changes and adjust the law accordingly.
So besides thinking about whether a
cohabitation promise or some other rights
should be enforced,
the legal system also has to decide which
part of government gets to decide the
question.
Similar questions arose during the same
sex marriage debates where the right to
marry with sometimes extended by courts
and sometimes by state legislatures
before the US Supreme Court mandated
that all states extend the right
changed social attitudes toward marriage
can be seen in how the treatment of
premarital premarital agreements has
changed until the mid 1970s most American
courts held that premarital agreements
and other contracts made quote in
contemplation of divorce unquote were
unenforceable as against public policy.
Section one 90 sub paragraph two of
the second restatement of contracts
continues to declare that a promise that
tends unreasonably to encourage divorce
or separation is unenforceable
on grounds of public policy.
The vast majority of courts,
however,
now treat premarital
agreements as enforceable,
at least in some circumstances.
Let's recap. Today.
We talked about how a contract may be
unenforceable on grounds of public policy
if the interest in enforcement is clearly
outweighed in the circumstances by a
public policy against the
enforcement of such terms.
We looked at a case that
held that cohabitation
agreements whereby an unmarried
couple allegedly agreed to share their
accumulated assets was not unenforceable
as against public policy.